[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 21
décembre
on le connaît comme animateur télé
journalistes il est aussi sur celle
bernard pivot prouve à nouveau son amour
des mots il était sur la scène du prisme
à elancourt la frontière entre le
théâtre et le lycée et parfois fine des
élèves guyancourt toi travaille avec des
artistes en résidence de la ferme de
bénévoles nous avons assisté à lui de la
représentation et soline détroit jeune
dessinatrice se passionne pour les
portraits d'artistes si une particulier
elle travaille au stylo bille et au
marqueur avec apostrophe bouillon de
culture ou encore les dictées on connaît
tous bernard pivot le journaliste
l'écrivain et l'homme de lettres mais il
est aussi sur scène pour présenter son
ouvrage au secours les mômes ont mangé
un spectacle conférence qui s'est tenue
sur la scène du prisme d'elancourt un
reportage sur les images de nicolas
d'andré j'ai toujours regretté
depuis ma naissance ne l'avoir pas été
le premier bébé au monde a parlé
il raconte la vie d'un homme un écrivain
de sa naissance à sa mort un homme
passionné par les mots tous les maux
sont prêts à venir manger là
l'inquiétude d'un romancier ou de tout
écrire en général toi parce que très
souvent
l'écrivain cherche un bon ils ne
trouvent pas toujours se méfier des mots
qui arrivent à toute allure qui vous a
plu sur votre langue souvent sont pas
sont des mots un petit peu d maculé au
secours les moments manger est au départ
un ouvrage bernard pivot journaliste
animateur lui aussi un homme de lettres
le met aujourd'hui en scène avec un peu
de lui même
j'aime les mots tout simplement parce
que ils sont et ils ont occupé une
grande place dans ma jeunesse dans mon
enfance ma maison je peux dire mais
surtout parce que je trouve que les gens
ne font pas assez attention aux mots
vivants nuit et jour avec des bouches du
rhône on sent que nous entendons que
nous lisons et malheureusement nous un
peu comme l'air qu'on respire on ne fait
pas attention à eux une nouvelle
déclaration d'amour pour la langue
française partager avec le public
un one man show à savourer sans craindre
l'indigestion
je n'arrivais pas à les garder à les
retenir comme eux en chiffres eux n'est
condescendance libations alors je notais
sur un petit carnet à 3 sous les
japonais par coeur mais comme les
biquettes il n'en faisait qu'à leur tête
et il s'échappe et de nombreux artistes
sont en résidence dans les salles
culturelles de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
certains quelques jours d'autres
plusieurs mois la ferme de bel ébat
accueille jusqu'en 2018 la compagnie in
cauda et cette résidence se fait aussi
au lycée de villa roi de guyancourt les
artistes de la compagnie yvelinoise
travaille avec des élèves de
l'établissement autour de plusieurs
pièces jeunes d'entre elles était
présenté vendredi dernier regardez ils
sont 6 6 lycéens guyancourt toi et
présente je marche dans la nuit par un
chemin mauvais d'ahmed madani ils
appartiennent à l'atelier théâtre du
lycée de villeroy
quand j'ai appris qu'on allait avoir la
chance que de vrais comédiens pourraient
nous apprendre à jouer bas je me suis
dit pourquoi pas tenter ma chance ça me
semble être une bonne expérience au
final basse en est une et quand j'ai
découvert ça basma franchement plus la
pièce parle de la mémoire collective et
personnelle
de cette transmission entre les
générations mais aussi de la guerre
d'algérie deux thématiques en lien avec
le programme de terminale
c'est un enjeu essentiel sur plan
pédagogique mais aussi sur le plan
citoyens je pense que questionner notre
transmission de la mémoire des mémoires
puisque pour chaque événement historique
différentes mémoires sont en jeu parfois
même en concurrence est absolument
essentiel est la pièce permet de
l'aborder de manière vivante
est ce que ne permettrait pas à une
analyse purement historique ou
littéraire un travail de plusieurs mois
en parallèle de leurs cours un
partenariat avec la ferme de bel ébat et
la compagnie yvelinoise in cauda nous ça
nous apporte beaucoup c'est à dire que
au fur et à mesure on faisait ça un peu
par obligation mais je ne parle 10 à 15
20 ans quand nous on avait commencé à
développer
effectivement la compagnie les ateliers
il se trouve qu'on se rend compte que
c'est c'est une part énorme de
transmission
quand on monte des pièces on cherche à
toucher un public à lui transmettre des
textes des choses comme ça qui me
regardent peut-être bien longtemps que
j'ai moins le temps la pensée et
d'autres personnes prochaine étape pour
ces lycéens des représentations dans
d'autres établissements des yvelines et
du var une exposition maintenant depuis
depuis le début de la saison culturelle
le public de la merise de trappes peut
découvrir huit tableaux un peu
particulier des portraits de stars
réalisé au stylo bille ils sont l'oeuvre
de soul in detroit une jeune trappistes
nous l'avons rencontré les images sans
signer nicolas d'andré
quelques très peu de couleurs une
simplicité qui attire l'oeil sur le
portrait et c'est le visage de jean
dujardin qui apparaît l'inspiration soul
in detroit la puise dans le monde
artistique
le choix des artistes fait vraiment par
rapport à mon inspiration est mon
inspiration je la puise dans la musique
donc c'est un son une chanson qui va
vraiment me faire qui va me parler qui
va m'emmener dans un univers propre à
moi une atmosphère et qui va me donner
l'envi de bas par exemple dessinée
samuel l jackson
joey starr certains utilisent la
peinture d'autres le crayon la jeune
trappistes ne se sépare jamais de son
stylo bille de son marqueur et de ses
écouteurs
j'ai pas mal d'années derrière moi de
cours d'art etc
j'ai déjà une bonne base et après avec
cette base je m'amuse et tout effet
voilà au stylo bille j'y vais en one
shot sait des choses de base simples
qu'on trouve de partout et je trouvais
ça important jeu ce monde de montrer ce
que j'étais capable de faire et de voilà
d'arriver à exprimer mes émotions à
travers des outils du quotidien 8
portrait sont actuellement exposées à la
mairie ce de trappes toute une saison
pour découvrir un talent 9 qui
transparaît derrière des trait de stylo
maîtrisé
cette semaine c'est gaël pinault qui
nous donne ce que son coup de coeur donc
on prend direct la direction d'autres
appelé le grenier à sel
bonjour c'est les vacances de noël alors
comme à chaque vacances nous avons nous
proposons des films pour les enfants et
nous avons évidemment le vaiana le film
de disney nous aurons aussi
prochainement ballerina nous aurons
aussi la bataille géante de boules de
neige et normes qui sont les grands
films de la fin de l'année et bien
entendu nous ne passons pas à côté de
roanne que nous aurons en vf et en vo
nous avons aussi demain tout commence
avec omar sy et mon coup de coeur donc
ça sera manchester baïse aussi que nous
aurons la semaine du 4 janvier
monster baïse aussi s'est réalisée par
kenneth lonergan c'est l'histoire de la
famille chandler qui lie est désigné
tuteur de son neveu patrick à la mort à
la mort de son frère et il se retrouve
confronté à un passé tragique qui doit
retourner dans la ville où il a grandi à
manchester
aux etats unis
et ça lui complique un petit peu la vie
le réalisateur kenneth lonergan nous
fait passer toutes les émotions des
personnages de l'histoire par l'image il
ya quasiment aucun mouvement de caméra
et irréfléchie chaque scène en fonction
de son espace et de la présence ou non
de ses protagonistes et dont on nous a
tant que spectateur on c'est là qu'on
ressent vraiment l'isolément du
personnage pour pour moi et pour
d'autres on pourrait considérer que
manchester by the 6 est peut-être l'un
des meilleurs films de l'année 2016 vous
retrouverez évidemment toutes nos
informations sur notre site internet
cinéma hell.com
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine des rendez vous
à noter dans votre agenda culturel et
bien sûr on se projette dans l'année et
la saison reprend dès le 4 janvier au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
avec de la danse
la troupe québécoise cas public donne
vie au conte du petit chaperon rouge
vous regardez
du côté des expositions la maison félix
de montigny le bretonneux accueille le
tuy ian simpson cet artiste réalise des
peintures sur porcelaine et c'est à
découvrir du 7 au 15 janvier toujours à
montigné mais cette fois sur la scène de
la salle jacques brel le 9 janvier vous
pourrez découvrir libres sont les
papillons
la pièce raconte l'histoire de cinq ans
de quentin qui essaient de se passer de
sa mère pendant un mois on regarde dans
l'extrait maison maintenant je vais
présenter madame vous le jure mais ça
parce que j'en ai envie
en fait j'étais venu d'irak en tant que
j'avais un problème avec la fermeture
éclair de ma robe
ah oui c'est évident un gros problème
pourquoi ça me rappelle quelque chose
qui est en train de tomber amoureuse ses
deux filles alors madame boulanger n'est
pas exactement la fille pilonnèrent
4,406 mais maintenant je me fous de la
filière l âme au repas le samedi 7
janvier c'est le lancement de la
troisième édition du festival plein feux
sur les planches quatre associations de
théâtre amateur seront sur les planches
de l'espace albert camus pour une
semaine de résidence des résidences avec
pour conclusion des représentations
chaque samedi
tout le programme est sur le site de la
commune et on termine avec le prisme
d'elancourt avec un spectacle pour
enfants qui ouvre l'année 2010 est entre
2 puis c'est une création sonore et
visuelle à découvrir à partir de 2 ans
regardez cet extrait
c'est une culture est maintenant
terminée je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis c'était le dernier numéro de
cette année 2007 je vous dis donc
à l'année prochaine et vous souhaite de
très bonnes fêtes
[Musique]